j'étais à paris en 1963 mère bordelaise
père corse
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est pascal obispo
julien leclercq
robben se répéter
j'adore cet endroit
oh
enfin c'est tout
à
julia ça nous fait rien jamais rien de
dérangeant et nationaux est ce que tu
peux nous avons été obligés de me
chanter pour le plaisir
attention ben moi si je te fais être un
petit peu dérangé a dit le président
c'est pas grave on vient juste de
commencer coude non pas attention
attention si c'est celui que la suisse
public va mal service public ce cas pour
le plaisir
y aura le temps de temps en temps de
refaire d'un homme un l'enfant et ses
blues le plaisir
merci
jara cela
genevois
le cas
m
cachez vous
non
l'inserm ont payé des enfants battus si
on peut y retourner
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux